(Risas)
Lo pensé bien y superé mis ansiedades y miedos.
Volví a la oficina de servicios sociales y exigí ver al supervisor.
En efecto, apareció,
y finalmente le permitieron al Sr. Ruiz solicitar su ayuda social.
Y logró ese beneficio por discapacidad para él y su familia.
Pero eso me enseñó una lección.
Me enseñó que tenía una voz.
El Sr. Ross también nos enseñó muchas otras cosas, incluido a Cesar Chavez
y muchos otros voluntarios.
Nos enseñó que podemos no solo exigir a la gente,
especialmente a los funcionarios públicos.
Y esto es algo que siempre debemos tener presente:
cada funcionario público trabaja para nosotros.
Porque pagamos sus sueldos con nuestros impuestos.
Y en realidad son nuestros empleados.
Algunos se vuelven líderes, pero no todos.
(Risas)
De vez en cuando surge un líder de allí.
Lo otro que nos enseñó Ross es que votar es sumamente importante.
Y no solo votar, sino salir a convocar a otros a que voten.
Ir puerta por puerta,
hacer llamadas telefónicas, hablar con los votantes,
porque muchos tienen dudas y no saben cómo votar.
Por desgracia,
sabemos que en muchos países a la gente no se le permite votar
porque hacen maniobras para impedir el voto,
como aquí en los EE. UU.
Pero si podemos intervenir como individuos y hablar con la gente,
podemos sacarlos de su apatía y asegurarnos de que voten.
Quiero darles un ejemplo de una mujer en nuestra fundación,
la "Fundación Dolores Huerta",
para mostrarles que a veces la gente tiene poder pero no lo sabe.
Y una vez que lo encuentran, hacen cosas milagrosas.
Leticia Prado es una inmigrante de México,
tiene solo educación primaria y habla muy poco inglés.
Pero estaba muy preocupada
porque los alumnos de la secundaria en su pueblo llamado Weedpatch,
en el Valle Central de California,
no podían salir a jugar en el patio
porque la calidad del aire es muy mala
en la parte sur del condado de Kern, California, en los EE. UU.
Junto a marido lograron que se apruebe una emisión de bonos
para construir un nuevo y moderno gimnasio
para los alumnos de la escuela.
Fue un éxito enorme.
Luego, Leticia escuchó el rumor
de que el director iba a cancelar el programa de desayuno
para los hijos de trabajadores rurales,
porque pensaba que era mucho papeleo.
Leticia fue electa para integrar el comité escolar.
Y mantuvieron el programa de desayuno y se deshizo del director.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Había otros rumores de corrupción en el servicio de provisión de agua local.
Y ella fue electa para integrar la dependencia que manejaba el servicio.
Luego analizó las finanzas de ese departamento
y descubrió que faltaban USD 250 000 de la cuenta bancaria.
Leticia llamó al gran jurado y se hicieron varios arrestos.
Y esto es solo un ejemplo de una mujer que nunca fue a la secundaria,
nunca fue a la facultad, pero encontró su poder.
Además, reclutó a otra gente de la comunidad
para postularse a cargos públicos,
y adivinen qué: todos fueron electos.
Creo que Leticia es un ejemplo
de algo que dijo Coretta Scott King, que quiero compartir con ustedes.
Coretta Scott King dijo:
"Nunca tendremos paz en el mundo hasta que las mujeres tomen el poder".
(Aplausos)
Modifiqué esa afirmación para decir
que nunca tendremos paz en el mundo hasta que las feministas tomen el poder.
(Risas)
Porque sabemos que hay una diferencia, ¿verdad?
No solo eso. Si queremos definir a una feminista,
pues es una persona que defiende los derechos reproductivos,
los derechos de inmigrantes, el medio ambiente,
los derechos de LGBT y los sindicatos laborales y los trabajadores.
(Aplausos)
Lo que también significa que los hombres pueden ser feministas.
Cuando pensamos en la feminización,
también debemos pensar en cómo podemos feminizar las políticas,
y no solo de los grandes países, los países ricos como los EE. UU.,
sino en todo el mundo,
nuestra política interior y exterior.
Y una de las cosas que podemos hacer para frenar las guerras y tener paz
es asegurarnos de que los países más ricos del mundo
también ayuden a los países en vías de desarrollo.
Hicimos esto en el pasado.
Luego de la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
cuando Japón y Alemania quedaron devastadas luego de la guerra,
los EE. UU. ayudaron económicamente a ambos países
para que puedan reconstruir su economía y sus empresas.
Y podemos volver a hacerlo.
Y podemos pensar en cómo ayudar a estos países.
Quiero dar un ejemplo de problemas que tenemos en los EE. UU., por caso.
Sabemos que en este momento
hay muchos refugiados de América Central que están en la frontera de EE. UU.
¿Por qué la gente abandona su hogar,
su hermoso hogar que visitamos como turistas?
Porque ahí no tienen oportunidades.
Y luego pensamos "Mm... bananas".
¿Cuántos cientos de bananas consumimos en EE. UU. todos los días?
Y en todo el mundo.
La gente de América Central,
¿obtiene beneficios de las bananas que consumimos nosotros?
Pues no.
Los beneficios van a las empresas de EE. UU.
Y pensamos que esto está mal.
Si la gente en América Central pudiera quedarse con algo de ese dinero
que pagamos por las bananas,
entonces no tendrían que abandonar su hogar.
No tendrían que venir como refugiados
a la frontera de EE. UU.
Y entonces, tal vez, muchos niños no tendrían que separarse de sus padres.
Sabemos que hay países
que tienen educación gratuita y asistencia médica gratuita
para todos sus habitantes.
Y ese país es Cuba.
Cuba tiene asistencia médica para cada uno de sus ciudadanos,
y también educación universitaria gratuita.
Son 11 millones de ciudadanos.
Entonces, si un país pobre como Cuba
puede tener este tipo de recursos, y sabemos que es un país pobre,
¿por qué algunos de los países ricos, como los Estados Unidos,
no pueden hacer lo mismo?
Creo que podemos lograrlo.
(Aplausos)
Pero sabemos que no sucederá
hasta que nosotros, la gente de EE. UU.
y la gente de todo el mundo
empiece a elegir funcionarios públicos en sus gobiernos
que se preocupen por los votantes, se preocupen por la gente,
que se comprometan para que los recursos disponibles
sean usados para sus ciudadanos, y no para la guerra.
¿Cómo logramos esto?
Tenemos que deshacernos de la apatía,
tenemos que involucrar a más gente.
Sabemos que si no podemos tener una democracia en los EE. UU.,
no podemos tener democracias en el resto del mundo,
a menos que la gente participe.
Es fundamental que todos participemos y digamos:
"Desháganse de la apatía, salgan a la calle,
vengan y súmense a la marcha por la paz y la justicia,
hagamos que la visión de Coretta Scott sea realidad,
la de tener paz en el mundo".
Hace poco fueron las elecciones de medio término en los EE. UU.
¿Y qué vimos?
Vimos que muchas más mujeres, gente joven, gente de color, LGBT,
fueron elegidos para ocupar cargos públicos.
Y ¿cómo sabemos que esto pasó?
Porque muchas mujeres estaban en la marcha.
Tuvimos la marcha de las mujeres en EE. UU.,
y hubo marchas de mujeres en todo el mundo.
Entonces ahora vemos que tenemos este potencial.
Tenemos este potencial de deshacernos de la apatía.
Y si involucramos a todos, si comprometemos a todos,
entonces creo que podemos hacer realidad la visión de Coretta Scott.
Solo quiero recordarles a todos, en todo el mundo,
que tenemos poder,
que la gente pobre tiene poder,
que cada ciudadano tiene poder.
Pero para lograr la paz que todos anhelamos,
todos tenemos que involucrarnos.
¿Qué decimos entonces?
¿Podemos hacerlo?
Decimos: "¡Sí, se puede!".
Y en inglés decimos: "Yes, we can!"
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)